be okay no yes
the parallelograms high perpendicular
height is exactly the same as the
triangles is perpendicular height
because the train was base this formed
the triangles bases are both formed off
of this line which is one side
imperative and their opposite vertex is
on the other side of the parallel right
so being at these are two parallel lines
the perpendicular height all the way
along will be exactly the same don't
make sense so for instance if I were to
draw another triangle in here right
which had the same base it would also
have the same area and I could draw a
triangle any way I could draw it over
here which had the same base it's not
the same height so you also have the
same area I can slide that base anywhere
I like and it's perpendicular height as
prism okay of every point of a parallel
line is like the same perpendicular
height happens with you and this is
between them that's why I'm gonna I'm
gonna keep going keep on keep on
thinking about it don't don't leave
behind but I'm going to keep me though
okay okay so now you remember it clicked
for me that I wanted a ratio to give me
this now look at pc and PR look at pc
and PR we've been thinking cuz i colored
it in right I've been thinking of this
triangle up here the red one the pc and
PR don't just eat reside in that red
triangle whereas today resign they
reside in my uncolored triangles here
you see that pcs there and pr's here
right now look at these two triangles
there I'm Colin right can you see
because of all parallel lines I've got
well mmm number one vertically opposite
I only need one more pair of angles how
about this guy and this guy
fans right why are they was too but why
the Stars you can in this case very good
I've got they are right and CD right so
there's my parallel lines and there's my
transversal you see that okay so I know
where I'm going now so i'm going to say
in these two triangles the uncolored
lines in triangle be P R and triangle
see p d right whoo all right which
angles did I say I wanted those angles
actually be PR and see p d there
vertically opposite and then the other
guys tore through alternate angles right
so I'd say our BP and DCP by the way
just to say on a note I have mentioned
this before but just to say it again
alternate angles on and I've got so many
parallel lines here that don't confuse
them so i'm going to name the parallel
lines I've got you might think that's a
bit excessive but actually it saves you
time because this is shorter to write
then parallel lines so why wouldn't you
right alternate angles on power lines
are oh I
and then you wrote that right I have no
problem with that but if you want to
save some time therefore I have two
triangles that are similar okay you're
almost there aren't you you're so very
close okay I'm proving similarity for
what purpose I want the ratios right so
I wanted um I wanted pc NPR right so
I've got PC and PR there so it looks
like i'm going to say let's compare pc
to up even down that's going to give me
p t and b you happy with that so what am
i comparing i'm comparing pc and PB
those sides aren't different triangles
but they correspond right yep that's a
corresponding pair and then I've got
these guys off at an angle their
corresponding here so that's what my two
pairs are okay and that's because
corresponding sides etc
okay now the rest of this fills out so
very nicely let's cross multiply so we
can say pc by P R equals p d by p be
happy with that that okay but i want to
get from here here which is just about
science I want to get to something like
this now don't freak out it's okay a
half that's a constant rate you agree
with that side of this angle right
that's also just a number whatever
depending on what CPR is ok so therefore
i can just multiply both sides by let's
go a half p CP R sine this if you
multiply one side by that number you
better multiply the other side by that
number sign c.p.r okay what's left so I
need the angles i need the angles don't
I ok how are you going to get across to
the angles
okay now remember i remember i went from
green to blue green and blue ah sorry
green black green black are the same out
there right so that's exactly right if i
can compare random black and sure
they're the same and this is almost the
black triangle right I just need this
other angle here which is vertically
opposite right right there okay so if i
say sign cpr should be the same as sine
what we call you it BPD right I've run
out of space over here but the reason is
medically officer you see that I've just
switched the able just see ya so now i
have my areas I've got the area of
what's this guy this is CPR all right
what's he equal to what is this triangle
it's the black one right BPD but I
started off proving that that area is in
fact bdq that was the first thing I said
after perpendicular home so therefore
despite the fact that these things are
not they emphatically not congruent okay
I'm you can even see in the diagram they
are not congruent okay but because of
the ways things being constructed equal
areas just 10 seconds right would you
would the students benefit from
especially cuz you skip seven sorry yeah